leur gilet il ne l'en fils plus il ne
nous autour de leurs cours les foulards
jaunes sont des anciens gillet ils
scandent les mêmes revendications mais
s'oppose au blocage et aux violences
mais par quoi qui veulent discuter
longtemps sont les fenêtres sur la côte
et on ne bloque surtout pas la route
je toujours en contact avec des gilets
jaunes leur réputation le descend
beaucoup maintenant on attend les jambes
hâlées gilet jaune est cassée gilet
jaune ils bloquent les voitures ils sont
là prométhée c'est pas de casser une
voiture ou de casser un magasin qui va
rapporter parce que les gens ils sont
comme nous ils travaillent ils veulent
gagner leur vie je suis toujours que le
peuple soit avec nous et qui nous
soutiennent pour compenser et arrêter
tous cas c'est thierry et dylan se sont
rencontrés un rond-point leur volonté
commune d'être pacifiques les a
rapprochés ils ont donc monté une
nouvelle association
je pense que le président sera peut-être
plus à même d'écouter les gilles foulard
jaune que les gilet jaune pour ceux qui
bloquent façon je suis contre eux parce
que ceux qui bloquent mot 600 d'entre
eux perdent de l'argent j'ai désiré qui
partait travailler ils sont bloqués sur
la route ch peuvent pas sur les
chantiers nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de ces gilet jaune mobilisés
ici depuis le 17 novembre
que pense-t-il de ce nouveau groupe s'il
faut vraiment sûr entendre par le
gouvernement c'est de faire quelque
chose qui sont concrets qui sait ce
pauvre nous emmener long des trottoirs
c'est pas la peine maugis répandre les
pacifique s'arrêteront pas si fiable
match a pas grand chose on n'est pas
seulement pour l'instant l'association
les foulards jaunes n'est pas déclarée à
la sous préfecture
[Musique]